other things that have been happening in
countries outside of ours
wnba star brittany greiner sentenced to
nine years in russian prison
so i i saw that i didn't really dive
deep into that
um but does that mean that she still
can't get extradited or traded for so
this is the most recent update this is
from daley wire wnba star brittany
greiner was sentenced to nine years in a
russian prison on thursday russian
prosecutors had argued that greiner who
was convicted of sneaking marijuana
vaping materials into the country should
serve nine and a half years in prison so
she saved half a year i guess the
request came during closing arguments in
a court outside moscow nearly six months
after the six foot nine inch wnba star
was nabbed at an airport with contraband
the us has been trying to negotiate her
release reportedly considering offering
a notorious russian arms dealer
imprisoned here as a trade so i'm not
sure if
that guy is maybe gonna
be swapped out for her or something but
it's a difficult situation do you want
to let a notorious russian arms dealer
go no
do you want a wnba star that had a vape
cartridge on her get jailed for nine
years in a russian gulag also know kind
of
kind of hard to
thread the needle i never meant to hurt
anybody and i never meant to put in
jeopardy the russian population i never
meant to break any laws here griner said
prior to the delivery of the verdict in
kim ki city courthouse i made an honest
mistake and i hope that you're ruling
that in your ruling it doesn't end my
life here i know everybody keeps talking
about political porn and politics but i
hope that is far from this courtroom uh
blah blah blah she said that she only
brought them to russia by mistake only
used kind of this is it grineer who
plays for the wnba's phoenix mercury had
flown to russia to finish a season for
ummc
ekka turinburg when she was arrested
team compete so she was over there
playing dude can you imagine
accidentally having even on purpose
thinking i can fly a vape cartridge in
and then getting
nine years in russia she's been there
for six months already she's already
detained
nine years in prison yeah so uh i think
a lot of the wnba stars the best of the
wmea they go
to other countries to make more money uh
i think they they pay
athletes for
uh for women's basketball and
particularly a lot more so
a lot of women do this this is a very
common practice but this is also not
just russia that has rules like this a
lot of middle eastern countries doesn't
bali have like uh crazy drug rules as
well like thailand is death if you're
caught with the wrong drug i think they
still have the death sentence for people
that are caught with the wrong drug
james was telling me about
some guy who had some marijuana and i
think it was in singapore
and or i'm not entirely sure what
country it was
i know it was southeast asia and
he had uh whipping like they had to they
whipped him no or like [ __ ]
a certain amount of lashes yes
what is this are we on a pirate ship
is this the 1700s what's going on dude
and then um he he was telling me another
story about how well he had a bunch of
stories about this uh because he's
covered it a lot but there was a guy
who
he was a a
football coach so soccer coach
and he um
he was taking his buddy to the airport
okay uh in i think it was dubai or
something and his buddy messaged him on
whatsapp saying
hey by the way i have a cbd pen that i
left in your car and the authorities
uh were able to hack that message and
arrested him
like they they stopped his car took him
out of there found the cbd or whatever
and i think he's rotting in jail was
that
i i think this one is a middle eastern
country right okay but again i'm not
entirely sure what the he said it was
like a football coach or something like
dubai and the united emirates is
somewhere you do not want to get caught
with drugs so i remember reading this
story a few years ago about a guy that
had a trace amount of marijuana on the
bottom of his shoe
on the bottom of his shoe so he'd stood
in maybe some marijuana maybe it was his
maybe it wasn't he was jailed for that
i've got another
news story here which is from april 2021
american facing years into by prison
after cannabis traces found in urine a
man who legally enjoyed some cannabis in
his home of las vegas is now facing
three years in prison in the united arab
emirates after being caught with traces
of it in his urine peter clark fleet
dubai on february 24th on a business
trip looking for a recording studio the
retired game designer then went to
hospital following a pancreatitis attack
it was reported to authorities when
doctors found hashish traces in his
urine which is considered possession in
the uae
oh
my god
[Laughter]
oh my god
that is insane that's that is insane
that's crazy dude medic medic
they were probably
forced to do that right it wasn't like
like it's part of their job i'm sure i
think they'll probably like they would
get obliged they would be obliged if
they see it to report it yes yes i don't
think they're probably going out of
their way but they'll have said what is
it that i'm going to do blah blah blah
we've found some weed we need to we need
to report this to the authorities
and if we don't we'll get in trouble oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure uh but
yeah that's that brittany greiner thing
is i mean rogan posted about it earlier
on today saying that
uh there's people that are still in jail
now in the us for drugs in states
for drugs that are now legal in those
states
that's wild and what's the what is i i
can't believe i can't think of it um
after a law is
like once the law has changed you can't
get charged for it or something like
that it was
uh i can't think of the the term but if
they
change the law
after you've broken it you can't go to
jail for it and i think vice versa
works as well oh and i don't know what
that what the term is but well there's
that that's that thing it's double
jeopardy or whatever it is where you
can't be trying
yeah yeah so that's that's definitely
but dude i mean it just
i feel
so bad for this britney grinder girl
like can you imagine being a an athlete
peak of your sport
randomly got something in your suitcase
nine years in a russian prison i wonder
if it plays out like what are the odds
that
she
is
never traded for to come back to the
united states and has to play out and
live out these nine years what if she
like learns russian
has to join a gang you know to survive
and [ __ ]
that'd be so cool
and then like once she's let go she's
like
like
kind of never the same and like wants to
stay in russia you know russian double
agent with her like new family she gets
like a new lease on life
well i'm glad that you're being very
hopeful about this i i wonder whether
she feels the same but uh yeah dude you
got to lean into it at that point
[ __ ] wild that's one of the things
you know for all that there's problems
with the western stuff
look at some of the drug laws in
different countries look at some of the
drug laws in the middle east in the far
east in russia
nine years for a vape cartridge i'd just
yeah it's very very very strange but
yeah i guess we'll wait and see and also
the other thing is let's say that
the best possible outcome here
is that the u.s loses a arms dealer
we get an arms dealer back out into the
world that's the best possible scenario
and then we get a wnba starbuck what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you